foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
accelerate your ivd assay development
with the unique support of the dynabeads
team
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them in to the ask
a question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers who
we Zing Market development manager
Thermo Fisher Scientific also Norway
erling singer singered friend senior
staff scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific Oslo Norway and tana Kim
Lindstrom Senior Management of r d
UI you may now begin your presentation
yes thank you very much for the
introduction
um so today we would like to talk a
little bit more about our product
database technology and our commercial
supply for the Dynamics and before that
actually we would like to talk about the
team because we have a very competent
and customer-centric
cross-functional team that love to work
with our customers and we want to
actually this week me and Arlene were
sitting in our Japan office and this
week we had a great meetings with our
customers
discussing technical questions and
troubleshooting uh we also discuss new
applications
and provide new Solutions so the this
type of this part of the team support is
part of our product and our
brand
so we are located in also in Norway we
have two sites one is in Oslo another
one is in lillestroom we have the feed
chemistry manufacturing site in
lillestroom and also r b related to
chemical chemistry Innovations for the
bid platform and then under in Oslo we
have the biological application site
site of the bid application and there we
have both r d and the production for bid
conjugation and fill and finish we have
300 employees in in Norway sites and
large part of the 300 employee actually
is focusing on Innovation and customers
uh and all these 300 employees actually
work with steinup bits technology we are
recognized as the center of excellence
in big technology
in summer Fisher not only we have the
chemistry know-how about bid production
process how to make the beats in high
quality we also have another team as I
mentioned in Oslo that focus on
applications
constantly innovating and identifying
new applications
so this is a very unique combination of
both chemistry know-how and biological
know-how in dynabis team and then based
on our knowledge we can also tailor make
particles for our customers based on
their requirements
and Dyno beats is widely used in the
mutual Diagnostics we have some
statistics more than 4 billion essays
analysis are done annually millions of
Life save saved because of this and a 50
seconds 50 tests per second
so that's quite uh large uh usage of our
technology and and because of this we
have a very high demand on the bid
production and we have increased uh our
production volume drastically last a few
years in order to support and Supply our
customers
so Dynamics is
more than 35 years old technology
and we are still continuing continuously
being selected by cutting-edge companies
for their innovation in Technologies
and we keep seeing expanding
applications for our beads these are the
main five area of applications one of
them is the immunotiagnostic assays and
protein purifications another one is the
molecular testing uh of uh
either the sample prep part of nuclear
acids prep and NGS sequencing
applications and our beads are also used
internally to make our iron torrent
instruments we also have cell therapy
products
that beads are used in T Cell isolation
and the activation for example in the
carti cell therapy for oncology blood
cancer
uh we also have the beads for cell
isolation used in CTC circulating tumor
cells for Diagnostic purpose in addition
to that we have another product that are
used for
virus isolation and exosome isolation
and recently we also launched two new
products for mRNA vaccine production
both for the solid in Virtual
transcription and also the MRNA
purification after the production of
mRNA
so what we are focusing on actually what
we are known for is the superior patch
to patch reproducibility and this means
that when customers use our bids they
can get very consistent results and
produce high quality and robustic assays
robust essays
and here we show that for different
sides of the beads we have monocytes and
mono Disturbed dispersed bits that show
in the figure on the left the peak the
the range of the distribution is very
narrow
and uh and the middle picture shows that
there is an even distribution of iron
oxide
and this means that these magnetic beads
will behave exactly in the similar way
in the in the ISA and the way that they
move to the magnets
and on the right it's showing the 10
years trending data on the patch to
batch
consistency and reproducibility and
there you can see with one example of
the beads you can see that the diameter
is well controlled as shown in bloopa
and the CV of the size distribution is
way below the
our criteria five percent is around
three percent actually
so this shows how well the process is
controlled and how well the bead quality
is controlled
and to make these high quality beads it
actually takes lots of effort and many
steps in the process production process
it's it's about 12 weeks and each step
is controlled with a critical process
parameters and measured with critical
quality attributes as you can see that
we have a long list of attributes that
are measured by QC method so in this way
we know exactly what we are producing
and we have good documentation on all of
these parameters and attributes and so
that if you if our customers see
I say performance difference we can go
back and Trace the
uh production all the way to raw
material and help our customer to solve
their challenges
and so we have a very broad range of bid
portfolio and mainly we have three
different sizes the 2.8 micro and 1.1
Micron are used a lot for the ivd essays
and the 4.5 Micron beads are mostly used
in Cell Activation and isolation
and on these three different sizes beads
we have different kind of service
surface chemistry and some are
hydrophobic some are are hydrophobic and
also neutral chemistry and so with um
these different surface chemistry we can
have pre-coupled beads with protein a
protein G and IGG also streptavidine
beads
and I will not go in so much in detail
now because our scientific experts will
explain more about applications for each
of these speeds
um on top of these product portfolio we
also have the buffer system we have the
know-how about Automation and
application workflow and so with that
knowledge we can help our customer to
develop their essays and best to
optimize their essays and if this
product portfolio is not meeting the
customer requirement we can also
customize dynabeats to meet customers
needs
so with that I'm handing the
presentation over to Adeline who's the
our immunodeagnostic as an expert
use my mic
hello
can you hear us
I'm sorry about this technical issues
but now it seems to be okay thank you so
much
yes so I will um
follow up on who is uh last slide where
she showed that we have a
wide selection of Diana beads for your
asset development needs and it can be
quite confusing if you are new to
developing immunosis using Dynamics what
to choose and what
is important when you are thinking about
the
how to develop the best possible essay
so when
we work with a customers in the
diagnostic field we like to work in a
more
close relationship a more partnership
basis so that during the first
feasibility phases Where You Are
considering us it's a new options
we can come in with some technical
suggestions
training
to map out more what of these different
products you need and which you should
start with
okay nice yes so um
once we have established a good starting
point for the feasibility testing and r
d phase you will move over into the more
development phase of your asset
uh work
where we know that it's really important
that we are able to provide you with
material that represents our
typical manufacturing capability so that
you can be assured that your assay
is robust and can use our product and
that our products are reproducible in
your hands
we can also assist you when you come to
the production phase for
recommendations for how to scale up the
manufacturing process and of course we
have a strong support team you know slow
in your commercial face making sure that
you have the material when you need at
the Quality you need
so this is I guess more or less the same
slide that um
planes these process and we also have a
success story that we have
selected here
where we get very good feedback from
the customer where
they had an established Elisa essay on
the market but they were not happy with
the throughput and the sensitivity of
this
allies assay and by the help of
switching to a bead-based assay and
using chemiluminescence and a automated
platform from an provider of chem
immunodeagnostic instrumentation
they were able to improve all their
parameters significantly so for instance
Sevenfold Improvement of the sensitivity
versus Eliza
Precision was improved
there the previous
day-to-day variation was reduced and as
say time and hands on time was certainly
a significantly reduced
and then
they are now also then by going through
this process with the first essay it
will be quite straightforward for them
to expand the menu on this instrument
and also develop new assays based on the
support
so
if you are familiar with analyze I say
and are
unsure about why you go for a bead based
assay and what are the advantages
there are two main points to um to
emphasize on
and one is that
rather than having the antibodies on the
wells of the plate meaning that they
analyte or the antigen in the sample
will have to travel a long way through
the sample before finding somewhere to
park a capture antibody to
join up with
with the beads you have these
distributed throughout the sample so
that there is a very short distance
between the amolite and the capture
agent the capture antibody
this means that the
kinetics are significantly improved
and we are also more flexible in how
much capture and antibody you add to the
sample
and also the um
the order of which you add the reagents
you do not need to have the capture
antibody with the sample first in some
cases it might be better to
have the detection of the body first and
then capture capture antibody later
do you have a much wider flexibility in
the assay design and the kinetics are
better
the other important
[Music]
main group of a
improvements and
points go into magnetic speeds is the
flexibility of having the Automation and
we will come a little back to that
on the right we have compare the Elisa
plate assay with a bead I say
using exactly the same amount of
reagents so we have the same amount of
capture antibody on the well as we have
on the beads in the bead based system
still you see that we
have a significantly faster ramp up of
the signal
and the top signal after one hour is
also higher
when we are
developing
um as I said we will
recommend different types of beads for
different kinds of assets and
applications
the main factor you have to choose first
December bead size
the advantages using the larger beads is
that these are a little more robust to
work with you normally get the lower
background binding because there is less
surface area
the smaller one micron bead
is preferred when you really need the
best or widest
range in the dynamic range in the assay
they're also sediment slower which means
that it's less critical to have
mixture mixing the sample and also in
the production before you feel your kids
it can be easier working with the
smaller Beats
the second
decision you need to do is to select if
you want a
ffinity based system such as a strip
table in bead which can bind any
biotinylated antibody or biotinylated
antigen
or for instance a secondary antibody
couple bead like a goat anti-mouse
coated bead can also be a generic bead
you can use for all your assays
in these instances
it can be very easy to develop new
assets because you have already a fixed
solid substrate you just need to add a
different capture agent
many customers still prefer to use
direct coupling to a chemically
activated surface
in order to have a more clean system
[Music]
and
avoid for instance you do not have any
issues with the biotin interference in
Step dividend assets Etc
there we have different chemistries to
choose from
carboxylic acid coated beads which are
familiar in the markets
they have a
inherent negative charge that will
in some cases influence the um the
capture efficiency
in these cases the epoxy bead which was
a neutral and steel hydrophilic might be
a good option
also if you have a small
antigen such as a
recombinant peptide in an infectious
disease assay
you are able to present this in a very
good manner on an epoxy hydrophilic
non-charged surface
because they will be very little
interference
from other serum proteins in the sample
the last option is the more hydrophobic
fossil activated beads which are more
similar to polystyrene plates where the
protein
antibody or antigen it's absorbed onto
the surface and you have a slow
formation of a covalent bonded to
stabilize the beads capture agents
conjugate
these beets have the highest capacity
and in most cases
giving a very good essay
but if there are
again
depending on what kind of
signal generation you are using what
kind of
antigen you are capturing or antigen you
are bound to the beads the selection of
the chemistry
might differ so we do recommend to test
different chemistries and then
uh move forward with what is giving the
best in the initial screen
finally
I talked briefly about
automation as a huge benefit for be it
based assays and this really
revolutionized the
centralized lab testing when this was
introduced in
in the 19 late 1980s
due to the fact that you are able to
load
different
assets onto the same instrument at the
same time
so that
one blood sample can be analyzed with a
selection of assays
another blood sample can be acid with
another selection of assays in a random
access format it's very certainly helps
the Physicians and the Laboratory test
Personnel to have the most efficient use
of the instrument and the best
way of handling results back to the
patients
with a beat-based automation you also
have the possibility for stat testing
such as so that prioritized patient
testing can be put
first in the queue and we added at any
time in during a run
you also
see that the manufacturing of the
humanistic kids
is much easier when you can make a large
bulk of capture antibody or capture
antigen on beads do a one QC test on a
large bulk and then distribute this into
the
each kid reagent package
rather than when you are working with
plate based system you can only do a
test by sampling during the coating of
all these plates which also takes a lot
of space in the manufacturer to to
handle the specific plate code
so as a summary these are the
main advantages in of moving to bead
based immuno assays
and we are here to help you in that
process
and also give more detailed help on how
you use the different beads and where to
start Etc
then I will hand it over to Hannah to
follow up on the molecular testing side
I would like to introduce to you the
dynabeat products for nucleic acid-based
application so dynabeads can provide
solutions for your workflow needs
ranging from nucleic acid extraction
um sequence enrichment as you can see in
the middle panel two even being a part
of your readout as a solid space for for
instance NGS Library preparation or
digitalized platform readers using the
bead as single units of single
however for this WebEx section we will
focus mainly on the nucleic acid
extraction workflows but should any of
the other application areas we have
interest used please reach out to us
so for the nucleic acid discretion I'm
bringing in the in the red circles in
the slide we can provide both generic
capture and specific capture based on
our 1.1 Micron platform the my one
platform and the n270 the 2.8 Micron
platforms
um
for generally nucleic acid application
we recommend the 1.1 Micron platform as
you can see on the same image at the
bottom of the north far left side and
the beads are quite ruffled
so this is done quite purposely so not
only do these 1.1 Micron platforms both
usual dynavates monocyte mono dispersed
low CV and high Dash to batch
reproducibility and robustness but here
we have also maximized the surface area
and this is to enhance the binding
capacity as well as giving faster
kinetics so together these enables
really reproducible and robust High
sensitivity workflows for nucleic acid
applications
so when we move to the next the big
circle for generic capture we have two
major different chemistries for the bit
surface
so we have the silent
um
coated beats for negative polar surface
and the carboxylic acid produces for
negatively charged surface
and depending on your buffer composition
in which you want to use these beads one
may actually work better than the other
so a general rule of thumb that we
recommend is that for more charge-based
workbooks we recommend the carboxylic
acid base but for more ketotrophic
alcohol-based precipitation workflows we
recommend the silent however there's a
big overlap between the best performer
so if you're ever in doubt please reach
out to us and we will be more than happy
to guide you there
and to further expedite your workflow
development we have also two versions of
high concentrate structures that can be
used in parallel with these three
platforms
these were developed in parallel with
the silent beats so they're a highly
optimized for use with dynabies in
nucleic acid extraction workflows
the first one is called the rare Target
depression purification buffer that can
be diluted into various concentrations
depending on your sample Matrix and
Target and Purity needs and this is
optimized for the use with sample
matrices that has low overall nucleic
acid content
the other one is called the Abundant
nucleic acid purification buffer and
this has been developed specific for
sample matrices with very high nucleic
acid constants such as cell cultures
blood and tissues
and I shall share you in the next
consecutive slide a little bit about how
to use these buffer together with a B
and if you look at the middle panel we
also offer specific capture workflows
for a rare Target enrichment
um here we also have two different beat
size platforms that we can offer the 2.8
Micron and 1.1 Micron B however once
again for this ultra high sensitivity
capture using specific capture
technology with oligos of your choice we
do recommend the 1.1 Micron the my one
platform for these as well for the
faster kinetics and capacity
um here we also offer the either strep
admin coded base for such applications
or custom couples choosing your own
oligos we can either provide you with an
Amic coupling workflow that has been
optimized for update or even take away
the pain of this optimization and
development by offering your custom
coupling surface to service
the advantage with the custom coupling
service that we offer is that it is a
proprietary coupling method which
enables a hundred percent directional
coupling either three or five primary
are all legal for the capture probe so
you will get even higher specificity in
your capture as well as full usage of
the all legal to be coupled on top of
your boot
so together we have a a building block
or legal like principles with these
buffers and workflows that we provide
for your workload to expedite your
workflow development
um
let's
so next I would like to share some of
our ready to go workflows using our
beats and buffers for
um to expedite your workflow development
so once again I would like to highlight
that these workflows are highly
optimized for a very um being used in a
quite a generic way so there they can
suit numerous different types of supple
matrices as from the get-go however
since it's so generic we there's a lot
of room for simplification
and a reduction in
component usage as what we would like to
provide is a starting point for your
workflow development to suit your sample
Matrix all the way to the automation
specifications
so here we have a three very
good starting points for your
development
the first one is the generic capture
workflow and it comes with two different
versions The Standard workload that you
see on the top row
um it is a simple life
binding triggered by addition of alcohol
such as isopropanol then you have two
series of washes uh the first wash
buffer one to wash away your purities
the second wash buffer to to wash away
any salt scareotropic cells or
detergents from the washing process
and then since there's an alcoholic word
for there's a small air drying step
upon which the nucleic acid is diluted
or Downstream amplification or NGS
rebate
um this is a highly efficient workflow
that can enable capturing of even single
viral Targets in the sample matrices
we also have an equally efficient
alcohol-free workflow that is optimal
for
um like being packaged into
cartridge-based systems so
for point of care for instance here it's
similar to our alcohol including
workflow however we also provide
alcohol-free components to trigger The
Binding of the nucleic acid to the base
as well as a fully alcohol-free wash
buffer 2 to enable the washing off of
the carotopic cells and impurities
without affecting the losses targets
and since it's an alcohol-free workflow
you have a small collapse step where you
don't have to go through the air drying
step and it can go straight into
dilution and into your readout platform
and the third one is a more of a proof
of principle workflow as this will be
dependent on
um like the customer probe design so to
say and that is a specific capture
workflow for your Target efficient High
sensitivity Target capture
here you will have to use our custom
coupling Service as the we have
discovered that directional coupling the
fully directional coupling to the beat
is quite vital for the super high
sensitivity capture of your rare targets
but once you have that probe design
to your liking and it can be coupled to
your Beats and that can be used in this
our low prep workflow
here are buffers and beats enabled life
is binding in a single step in less than
10 minutes
um or actually less than five minutes
and it can be shortened down as quickly
as two minutes at least perceived by
your perfect console board it has a very
simple wash just one single wash to wash
off all the impurities and even the
illusion is optional
um has c-speed and nucleic acid complex
has shown to be fully compatible with
PCR or isothermal amplification work
detection
so if you put that all together you can
collapse a sample extraction workflow to
under 10 minutes
so I'll show you in the next couple of
slides some results that we have done
with these three different workflows
so this is our standard
alcohol-based workflow based on our
silences and the silent rare targets
nucleic acid purification buffers and we
have tested three different viral titers
high low and medium and compared our
beats performance against some of our
competitors
and on the left the y-axis you can see
the CT values for the detection of these
three viral titers and as you can see on
the far left we have the silent workflow
and they for all three titles we can see
by far the lowest cities it's a
detection at least two CT slower than
our closest competitors for all three of
the the whole entire range of the viral
patients as well
so we showed that with dynabies and
especially with our in combination with
our proprietary buffer system we can
provide the highest sensitivity
detection of your viral targets
in the next slide
we are also showing the comparator with
our standard High performing extraction
workflow using alcohol with our
alcohol-free workflow so entirely
non-alcoholic workflow using our
non-alcoholic trigger and non-colic wash
buffers to wash these
and here once again we've tried it
tested it compared it with three
different viral titers and also DNA and
RNA model systems that we've used here
or viral models
as you can see here once again the CT
values are on the y-axis
we have equal performance between the
standard and our alcohol-free workflow
in both DNA and RNA targets over the
entire range of viral titers tested
so it shows that
you don't lose any efficiency just by
going fully alcohol-free or you're going
to carrying
and finally
um this is our proof of concept workflow
the low prep the specific capture
workflow or using our propriety coupling
service and buffer systems to generate a
Target capture for your high sensitivity
capture the target once again here we
used a DNA virus for
measuring the workflow efficiency
so in this workflow we have used a
illusion-based workflow so we had used a
five minute devices binding
washing that took about one minute
and illusion that we use two-minute
solution at 50 degrees
so the entire workflow that we tested
the high sensitivity capture efficiency
on to less than eight minutes
so here we have looked at
um
a broad range of viral targets ranging
from just 14 copies up to 100 000 copies
and you can see that the entire range we
have about 80
capturing efficiency despite having a
less than 10 minute capturing workflow
and this is something that we can help
you design should you come with your own
probes that you would like to put onto
these boots
and this is not only something that is
how do you say efficient at sample
capture for these rare targets but also
it is fully compatible with your
Downstream detection assets
so here we show in both qpcr and
isothermal amplification
the both the emission workflow versus
bead and nucleic acid that you just
captured just dropped straight into
an amplification workflow
so the blue bar shows this like an
illusion step you remove the beads from
the dissection and the yellow bars show
speed and nucleic acid as a complex put
into the detection once again the CT
values are on the y-axis and as you can
see they have equal if not even better
performance when you use your Target or
the nucleus accomplish straight into
your extension system further collapse
in the entire workflow steps
so this means that by using the Beats
nucleic acid capture nucleic acid in
your detection system you can come down
with your sample prep workflow to as
short as five minutes
so in summary these workflows are not
only very efficient they're extremely
robust at capturing those very very rare
Targets in an unbiased throughout a very
broad range of different viral titers or
even bacterial times we accepted and
these are inherently scalable as well
depending on how much sample Matrix you
would like to put in versus the target
concentration you need at the end
and of course since this is these are
bead based capturing workflows they're
inherently automatable as well
so should you have any further questions
about either the workflows
um the capturing mechanism targets or
even automation needs uh please reach
out to us and we'll be more than happy
to help you
so now I will leave over the final two
three
okay
thank you Hannah
so now you have seen a glimpse of our
product and Technology offering and I
would like to bring back our uh
discussion or or the topics back to the
commercial Supply and partnership
um so we value we provide value beyond
our product not only we have a great and
high quality product we also have a very
good Supply capacity and security we
emphasize a lot on the quality and we
have a lot of no house on application
workflow analytics process
and
we actually want to be not just a
supplier of the product we want to be a
partner on your journey to success
so each customer is unique to us because
every customer has their own unique
needs and characteristics so what we do
is that we design usually design a
starter package for each new customer
we have flexibility in our pricing model
so that we can tailor make this pricing
and Supply offer we have a deep
conversation about how
the customer is seeing their needs and
their growth and then we design and this
offering to the specific customers we
also as mentioned we have customizations
flexibility so that the product can be
tuned into your needs we also assign a
designated product manager to have a
close contact with you
to direct your request into our entire
organization so that we find the right
people to support you
and on top of that we have directed Andy
to r d consultation and so that we can
help you troubleshoot optimize and scale
up
um and uh as I have mentioned that at
the beginning we have been in this
industry for more than 35 years
um we are known to be a trustworthy or
safe choice of OEM
partner partnership partner
and we produce products in very high
quality and we continues to expand our
capacity to serve our customer and we
would like to grow our ourselves
together with our customer
also as a part of thermal Fisher we have
a worldwide infrastructure to secure
your supply
um so please if you are interested in
our commercial supply for dynabeats you
can find out more information on our new
web page for database technology OEM
and you can also experience it for
yourself with our cross-functional team
support by filling this form in the
website to get to get custom support
and so I'm
responsible for the business development
and Commercial Supply licensing for
Dynamics for the Apec region and I'm
really looking forward to meet you in
person and help you to accelerate your
essays faster into the market
and we are also doing more
webinars in the coming quarter q1 next
year
uh on liquid biopsy on multi-ohmics
application so please stay tuned for our
next webinar
thank you very much
now I hand it back to Megan
for questions
yes thank you Hui erling and Hannah for
your informative presentation I want to
encourage our audience to now submit any
questions you may have just click on the
ask a question box and click Send
while we allow the audience time to
submit any questions I would like to
turn it to our speakers again for any
additional comments you may have at this
time
[Music]
yeah so while we're waiting
um I just want to say thank you very
much for attending this webinar and
because uh we have a limited time and
there are so much more we want to tell
our customers or tell you about and so
we are developing new webinars and yeah
hope to see you again
great thank you so much it doesn't look
like we have any questions at this time
but I think I want to thank you all
again Hui erling and Hannah for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions we do not have time for and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye